you have google engineers who are the
whole comfort of rationalism and
would mock anything spiritual or
religious but then can't wait to show
you the photos of their weekend at
bernie man where they ran around half
naked in the desert off the face of the
psychedelic bernie
yes saying oh man i was in touch with
the universal cosmic oneness
it's funny that you would say that
because that's a direct quote from
the old testament the bhagavad-gita and
buddhism even actually has a very
sophisticated
2 000 year old way of naming what you
think is just i had mushrooms and
felt one taste
can you tell for the people who don't
know give us your background how did you
end up here
how did i end up here i
from a young age was
utterly fascinated with the big
questions
of what we're doing here how does this
whole thing work
what is this wondrous strange experience
that we are having
on a ball of rock hurtling through space
at 67
000 miles an hour and in the world i
came from
if you're interested in those things you
become a
spiritual teacher a pastor you help
people
explore the big mysteries that's what i
did that's what i've been doing for a
long time now
and i love it so books tours
films events um
however i can help create spaces where
people
can discover who they are and what we're
all doing here
come in you could have gone down a
couple of routes there couldn't you
could have been
psychology philosophy physics
mathematics
public service in some form or another
yeah and it was interesting my dad was a
judge
for 44 years so he woke up every morning
put on a suit went to a courthouse
and presided over trials so so he had
uh this trying to get the right word
this
old school sense of public service you
know what i mean like
there's this proper dignified role that
you play in society you know what i mean
where you you give yourself to the
greater good as an act of service in his
case the
administration of justice so i sort of
grew up in this setting
where you're here to help contribute
like that was like baked into the dna of
the home i came in
came up in yeah where are you from where
is home
i grew up in michigan so in between
chicago and detroit
okay is that quite typical to have this
wholesome
uh sort of oh yeah oh yeah it was
midwest
you go to uh soccer practice
although you properly refer to it as
football correct um
you take piano lessons you go to the
the public school which for you all like
like the school that everybody goes to
not like a private thing you just um you
ride your bike
to school you know what i mean like
there are like it was
um yeah you do your homework
you have a dog yeah it was yeah it was
yeah my parents though
i'm trying to think how to say this
there was a
an intellectual restlessness an
intellectual spiritual restlessness they
were always reading
having interesting people for dinner
like giving me
number one high school my dad being like
where's this guy c.s lewis you might
find him interesting
like there was this sort of searching
exploring
endless conversations about the big
things that was sort of just
normal part of life it's a good way to
instill some curiosity at a young age
yeah yeah and my dad used to say
you know um he had all these like
phrases
that like sort of get etched as a kid
stuff you're told over and over like
some of it sticks and some of it you're
like what was that
but there was one thing he used to say
the greatest gift
you can give yourself is to find work
that you love
so your original question
around the age of 20 i gave my first
sermon
and i'd been in a band and the band
broke up and i was trying to figure out
i was gonna do with my life and i
volunteered to give a sermon at like
this chapel service
and suddenly i saw the sermon as an art
form
like a revolutionary
poetic uh
counter-narrative subversive
art form and i was like oh i'm gonna do
that that's what i'm gonna do that's how
it started
that is not what i would have typically
thought of as someone giving sermons i
appreciate that
my experience in church has been limited
since i was in school
um i've i've gone when i've when i've
had to i suppose which is usually
christmas
christenings and funerals and weddings
and stuff and also
i don't really know what the equivalent
in the uk would be i i'm fascinated by
the concept of a mega church
uh and i want to kind of right yeah
really delve into that what
what is a mega church
right so
um in america you have this phenomenon
where you could say it's just
religion but it's religion politics
economics generally all these things
get duct taped together in certain
places
and you get big churches like really big
um and
it's a relatively new phenomenon and
when i
started studying theology and became a
pastor
there were a few of them which were
almost like have you heard about that
you know what i mean
like there's one one state over you know
what i mean like what is that
um but then when i was in my 20s i
started a church
um i was like there's got to be a better
way to talk about
what it means to have a spiritual vision
for life this has got to be a better way
to do it
it's almost like basic innovation
there's got to be some better way
to explore spaces where people can grow
and learn and become better humans
um but i started this church and then it
grew into what is called a mega church
so what's up what defines it is it like
the number of people guy who was like
i was like the guy like the rage against
the machine like you know what i mean
stick it to the man and suddenly
suddenly i was the man you are the man
now you're the man
it's a very strange i mean within a
couple of years there were 10
000 people coming on a sunday so try to
imagine
there were 80 employees within a couple
of years
so picture like people with orange vests
and those
lights that they use at the airport to
help guide planes into space parking
cars
and picture um people giving money
like well you go to a church you donate
right like
all these sort of accustomed behaviors
people had
and yet for me and my wife and friends
we were doing like a giant art
experiment
like could you give most of the money
away to the poor
but could you do giant art shows where
you invite thousands of people
to make art and display it could you
write your own music
and sing it you know what i mean like
for us it was this
um do like a very diy
sort of post punk keep it lean and mean
and
low to the ground and yet this
phenomenon
happened i mean it was 20 years ago
that we 22 years ago that so it feels
like another lifetime but
can ima imagine a small town in the
midwest
and this thing just explodes
like relatively overnight how big is the
building
uh we outgrew the first building and so
i had to start doing the sermon
three times on sunday to fit everybody
and then somebody gave us
a mall so a guy said i have a mall
it's not making a lot of money there's a
bunch of empty stores can i just
give it to you and you buy the parking
lot
so we literally took over an american
mall
i know i mean i'm telling you the story
like wait that's what happened that's
what happened
yeah yeah what's the what's the biggest
number of people that you've
sermoned to at once
oh over the whole
what an interesting question i remember
speaking in my early 30s
um getting invited to speak at like
outdoor festivals
and i remember speaking at a festival
in between all these bands and
you know like when you're speaking on a
stage people are familiar with this
you look to your left and then you sort
of look across the crowd to your right i
remember while i was speaking
a second voice in my head going man when
you look far left and then you
swing over to look far right that takes
a while
and afterwards you know what i mean i
was like
i think this might be a lot of people
i'm not sure and then afterwards i said
to one of the promoters like
hey just out of curiosity like how many
people was that and he's i remember he
said
completely deadpan i think we sold 120
000 tickets
[Laughter]
like like he was a little fuzzy on it
you know what i mean i think we sold
about 120 000 tickets
so i'm sure i don't know who knows
that's insane so i mean again
for me thinking about the way that i
would consider like a typical
vicar you know like in the uk like you
know kind of
this uh very sort of regal
older gentleman who he's he's got the
the white the white collar
um and you know is surrounded by oak
everything's oak and you've got sort of
very kind of baroque architecture
um that that like trying to picture
my vision of the guy that stands and
gives a talk
at a rock concert is oh there's
a discontinuity there
absolutely i remember the first time i
came to the uk fall of 2006
i was doing a short tour and somebody
had set up little gatherings
and the vicars that you described would
like show up
because they'd been listening to the
sermons or they'd seen the films i was
doing or read the books and
they would have questions and it was so
great because this love like
kind-hearted lovely folks like so
um is your baptistery look and i'd be
like um
you know whatever you have in your head
man dude love you but like just get rid
of everything you have in your head
because that's i'm not gonna have any
idea what you're talking about
[Music]
what are the uh yeah what are the what
are the preconceptions of a mega church
pastor i know that in your book
everything is spiritual you talk about
kind of subverting those expectations
people come up to you and
basically say you're not what i expected
what did they expect
right right right well what happened
like in the book when i talk about
this i saw it as an endless
discovery like you're a student so
um well what does quantum physics have
to tell us how about biology look at art
theory
look at this ancient text look how these
people interpreted this ancient text
for me it was this endless process of
evolving and growing and following where
it leads and the expectations of a mega
church pastor was
you're building something and so you say
what you say
to build it so you're not
growing or changing it's stability
you're offering people that's how you
build an institution
so i can i mean i literally would do
interviews
and the person would say it seems if i
look at your work over the past few
years like you're growing and evolving
and i'd be like yeah that's the job
and the interviewer would say no
i think the java mega like they just had
never you know what i mean it was like
wait you're a spiritual leader you're
supposed to be the exact same person
you've always been
it's like no the job
is to grow that's that's what we're
doing here
um so uh
i just kept noticing there was a game
face that mega church pastors would
often have
like what you say to keep the
organization
going in the quote-unquote right
direction and then there was the
personal life of the mega church pastor
which was
what they were reading what was
happening in their life and generally
like a split
almost like they'd step on stage and
have a persona and step off the stage
and be this other person
and right away i was like i'm i can't do
that
the only way it works is to have it be
this
authentic genuine path of discovery and
i'm sharing with people what i'm
learning
and you follow it where it goes still
that's the only
only game to be playing here i get it
yeah and it was very difficult very
painful
very yeah it was it
it was very very difficult to be in this
i'd even created it so it was very i
don't know what the word is limber or
flexible
and yet it still had all these cultural
assumptions that i couldn't do
yeah it was very painful for a while
there
i think typically whenever you have an
organization that gets large
anything like a big sports team you know
like you have a big sports complex
that's got a bunch of different junior
leagues in it and an
adult academy and a junior academy in a
fourth second
thirds yeah you know like when you have
that inevitably
it's harder to enact change there's more
politics that need to be played around
with
and the realm of religion spirituality
uh metaphysics that is not
there is like a you know the law of
conservation there's like some sort of
fundamental law
to do with the amount of [ __ ] that
you're gonna have to deal with when an
organization gets to a certain size
and it gets this kind of critical mass
absolutely uh and you're not you're not
exempt from it either
oh i love it i mean let's talk about
your premier league right now like look
at manchester united ollie
all he's got to do is win games but then
is that comment that he made
actually a reference to the board is he
actually saying to ed you need to give
me more money in the transfer window and
then how about the academy
and there is no director of football
development who should be developing an
academy that's why we're having to go
out
like it's like no no just win games and
he's like no no this thing
has got more layers i've got more pieces
um yeah yeah the thing gets unwieldy at
some level
it really does very normal thing so so
religion is not unusual in that regard
no not at all what does the word
spiritual mean to you
that this experience we're all having
here
it's dodgy and awkward and heartbreaking
and strange and
takes all these unexpected twists and
turns and failure
and pain and yet
there's something just below the surface
that never stops inviting you
to some sort of new creation so when i
ask people
what are the three or four or five
events that have most shaped you into
who you are
what people always people never talk
about well i got a pay raise
or i went on holiday and i said what are
the events that most
affected who you've become people always
talk about suffering loss heartbreak
and pain and they always witness to
something happening
in the midst of it so spiritual
is the depth of life it's this animating
energy that's been
moving the universe forward for 13
billion years
as it endlessly expands present
around and in each of us and
never stops inviting us to new futures
and
new imagination and new possibilities
that's a really short
slash long answer yeah but for many
people spiritual
for many people when they were told
spiritual they
think of something otherworldly leaving
this place
not but spiritual is economics politics
art
earth soil regenerative farming
how we care for the vulnerable and on it
spiritual is the depth of all of life
it's the thing happening just below the
surface and pretty much everything
i think the difficulty that a lot of
people have with the word
spiritual is that it kind of comes
attached with a ton of baggage
right like it's absolutely a word
absolutely a word which
has grown out virtuously grown out of
established classic spiritual practices
and then
also more recently kind of just been
hijacked by anyone who wants to talk
about
spooky stuff and you know
yeah precisely which and when you that's
like a kind of a double-ended attack
like a pincer movement of two different
groups one which is
completely entrenched in tradition and
unchanging
and has set this very kind of um firm
foundation
for what it could or should be and then
you have this total
new wave version of it that's kind of
throwing the establishment upside down
and
you're suspicious of the old the old
guard because
maybe they haven't updated their
thinking in quite a while and you're
suspicious of the new guard because
they've been around for so long that how
the hell can they know what they're
talking about
you have just done a brilliant job of
summarizing
a world of philosophy and current
thought
yeah the one says this is how it works
there is nothing new or innovative or
adaptive just follow these rules come to
our services at this time
obey and it misses the adaptive
ongoing inviting aspect
it doesn't know what to do with quantum
physics it doesn't know what to do
with what we now know about the
condition of the earth it it is
sometimes paralyzed in the face of the
great
questions of the day the other rejects
that completely and often rejects any
depth
it surfaces it is reductionism it is
you are just a collection of cells
neurons and synapses
get over it your brain created all this
anyway it's just a series of impulses
firing up there
but the problem is that leaves a person
disconnected from the depths and a
little bored
and it doesn't know what to do with the
great mysteries of life
consciousness itself you and i are aware
that we're aware
um that is the mystery at the heart of
the human experience that
continues to be an elusive mystery
so there is an integrative path that
takes the strengths of both of what you
just pointed out leaves behind the
weaknesses and duct tapes them together
which is what i'm trying to do in the
book
i think especially in the 21st century
i'm on this
flex at the moment a lot at the moment
thinking and talking about this
particular viewpoint
the value of being cerebral in 2020
is so high that i think it can
disconnect us from the the sort of magic
that we have around
now i'm not someone who is
religious i would class myself the worst
like the absolute
worst classification which is someone
who's non-religious but spiritual
which just sounds like somebody somebody
who
wants to have all of the enjoyment of
sitting on a meditation cushion all of
the wonder of looking at the night sky
but none of the discipline of having to
stick to any commandments
like that's what it sounds like i want
to do which isn't the truth i promise
you it's not the truth
but the sabbath that's not what you want
to do never know the sad thing is
that i think enjoying the fact that you
can have transcendent experiences
even if they're just biochemically
produced even if the only reason that i
feel a sense of
awe or a sense of wonder or a sense of
connection the connections the oxytocin
and the sense of also dopamine
like you can just uh deconstruct it all
the way back down
but it doesn't help anyone that isn't
you
to understand phenomenologically what
that sensation
feels like and that that is the
challenge
that you you've got to rely on people
who are the best wordsmiths on the
planet to get one percent of the way
there
to explain what ore or dread feel like
absolutely absolutely there's something
about this experience we are having
that the intellect can follow it
a certain distance down the road and
then it always transcends
your cognitive capacities and you're
into some other
space which is why poetry art
you think about all of the
most helpful expressions generally move
you beyond
the narrow parameters of linear logic i
love how you were
about to say you're spiritual but not
religious you were already throwing up
in your mouth
that you were going to be the guy saying
this and yet it is
how you would describe
this experience yeah i get it i get it
but the problem with that
yeah the fact that i have to say it
identifies the fact that
spirituality has been
uh carabiner hooked onto religion
that if you say i'm spiritual people
presume if you're not wearing elephant
pants with dreadlocks
i.e new wave religion that you must you
must be just like a slightly non-normal
non-religious looking religious person
um so the caveat there again is
more really just a semantic one um that
is a part of the etymology of where that
word has grown up
through the years yeah what's
interesting though if i come
like a last summer i was on tour in
in your fine land and
um i would and i'll
i will interact with all sorts of people
from all sorts of backgrounds and
some of them are rooted in a lineage the
christian mystical tradition judaism
buddhism some
come out of yoga some are acad come out
of academia
but a sense that there's something about
the soul
that is transcendent and timeless um
there is a common space where all these
people meet
exactly what you're describing and some
came in through science
because they were like wait a second
this can go pretty far but then
there's something else going on here
some came in through religion
some came in through joseph campbell and
mythology
and look at this experience we're having
and look at the ways in which people
have named
this some have just haven't had an
intuitive sense
their whole life of what you're saying
of the transcendence
so they're just like just give me a
cushion let's
talk about that yeah yeah there is a
new space with all sorts of people
who are exactly what you are describing
and it's not weird and it's not woo
and it's yeah yeah yeah
so that's that's that that is um it's a
pretty exciting thing happening
i think so but your analysis your
analysis is spot on good
i'm glad you're also you you know you
might um
i was thinking when you were just
talking you made an interesting point
i do these sessions where people
um i was doing them in person now with
the world of way it is on zoom
where people tell me what they're
working on and how they're stuck
and then i sit with them and and watch
while they get unstuck
and the whole premise is i don't know
who they are or
what they do or any background on them
so they just tell me
hi mom so-and-so this is what i'm
working on and it might be
an artist it might be a ceo might be a
heart surgeon it might be a
guy who has a podcast like you and then
they
generally take them about two minutes to
explain what what's the stuckness
but what i think what you might find
fascinating is
when i invite them sometimes i'll even
use an image like
to sink down from head into heart
um because there's all this chatter in
our heads
there's self-doubt there's cursive
there's the voice of the expert on our
shoulder telling us how it's supposed to
be done
but you would find it fascinating how
many people when all i say is
so sink down into heart
whatever that means to you and tell me
what you find
how many people instantly find clarity
like it's almost like they go into a
deeper part of their being
than just that lovely synapse firing
you know what i mean absolutely man i
mean yeah you know
i see it again and again and again and
again and again there's all this clarity
right there
in the person again to
to drive home the point that i made
earlier on because i'm reflecting on it
as you as you speak
i don't and you don't need to either
attach some other worldliness if that's
not your inclination you don't need to
attach something
in order for this to not be effective
and real it can be an accurate
representation of the way that we
operate within the body
to say that if you are able to mindfully
reduce
chatter like you could reflect it as
going from
the uh what's it called
not the typical network what's the thing
that you switch off when you meditate
people are going to be screaming into
their into their airpods uh
there's there's two there's two systems
that work in the brain and um when you
meditate you turn off one
and you turn on another one that is a um
a way that a neuros a neuroscientist
would look at you
and say this is what is specifically
happening in the brain
the fact that you have created a
narrative
you've like personified the um
thought process right into kind of words
that seem
a little bit easier for people to
understand if they're to say
right i need you to switch off your
autonomic nervous sense and you know do
like we need to really focus on getting
the parasympathetic response moving and
we need to blah blah
like you know people don't know what
that means and
we live we live our lives in stories
this is something that jordan peterson
talked about in a live
a live um event i went to see him at he
said
thomas the tank engine has a face why
does thomas the tank engine have a face
he's a tank engine
he doesn't need a face but we gave him a
face because we personify things you
know
you think you talk about your car in
that way you say oh
you know she doesn't like being in the
cold like or you know
you talk about the the cooker in that
way as well like you give
things you bestow upon them
personalities um and i think that
rejecting that rejecting the fact that
we have to use we are storytelling
creatures
we have to use things that are narrative
based
um absolutely in the face of
scientific truth you know in a
enlightened world
i think that you lose a competitive
advantage there
because it's quicker and easier for me
to know what you mean when you say sink
down into your heart
than for you to try and explain to me
how the parasympathetic and sympathetic
nervous response works
yes yes and that is absolutely well said
and that if you can if if you if a
person can read that
not through the lens of frustration how
come there are all these different ways
of naming these experiences
and see it as this is like
this is part of the joy of life look at
how those people
named that look at how the scientists
name that this poet over here there's a
12th century
sufi mystic named roomie look how roomy
names this listen to the latest
radiohead album
look at this um look at this architect
how this architect
imagines this physical space and what
that says about what it means
to be human and obviously you have a
massive history of religion
some of it really really destructive and
divisive but some of it
extraordinarily helpful stories
about how to interpret this experience
we're having
what does matter is it headed somewhere
yeah yeah i love it
i love it good when do you see and
actually to be honest with you
this is what happened to me going back
to that mall
and all those people is
i kept noticing wait wait wait wait wait
this whole giant machinery this thing
that i'm a part of
it's actually at its heart about having
a fully human experience
that's actually the thing that that i'm
trying to do here you know what i mean
and it's got all these layers of stuff
but underneath it all
what's it mean to be human what's it
mean to be fully alive
where is the joy and meaning and
satisfaction
and that all of this apparatus and
tradition lineage i come from
if it doesn't help that and serve that
then i'm not bringing it with me
it became this like does it help
does it okay great otherwise not
interesting
yeah that was a huge thing that happened
to me
where do you see most people going wrong
on a
spiritual journey
wrong probably stuck in categories
that that it's right or wrong versus
who are you what has
what's in front of you what's the next
step what's it look like so
okay let's use the phrase wrong my
experience most people
it becomes way too complicated they get
stuck in their head
and they literally argue their way out
argue themselves
out of the next
step which is generally fairly
straightforward so oftentimes they have
a script
they were handed family authority
figures
professors mentors experts their boss
that's like this is
this is how you play the game and yet
something within them
knows they're here to do something
slightly different
so there's this tension or they simply
kept
going and the people around them at some
point stopped and settled
they kept exploring kept growing kept
searching
and most of the time
that's what's interesting so your path
if we were going to why you're doing
this today talking to me
i imagine there were key moments when
you were like um
i sense this is how chris does it
and there were probably key moments when
you were like
i know everybody around me is like this
is the direction to take
but something within me knows this
is the direction to take and you either
don't take that direction
something within you dies or you take it
and all the risks and
pleasure and everything that comes with
it yeah
that's how that's why i would say for
many people it got
way more complicated than it actually is
i think
this loops back to what i was saying
before about how much we value being
cerebral
um you know i i love you you're being a
utilitarian i love
the um the cold comfort of rationality
as pierce brown puts it in his
fantastic red rising series i like
the the comfort blanket that having
input process
output gives me because it allows me to
try and bring some sort of order to
chaos that's going on in the world
but what you've touched on there is a
very easy
test for people that are listening and
thinking yeah this sounds good mate but
i'm not really for that whole kind of
spirituality thing
many of the best decisions that we've
made are built on gut
instinct now good instinct is like this
weird
bizarre aggregate of all of the
subconscious
experiences and the the wisdom that we
have accrued
you know you're speaking to someone and
you if you just feel something's off
i don't know what it is i just don't
feel walking down the street you see
some guy
on the right hand side you're just not
really too sure about what it is
and if i said why did you cross the
street what was the reason
for you crossing the street you would
say right right right i don't know
i don't know the reason that i crossed
the street i just felt something was
wrong
right okay so what are we talking about
here are we talking about
super spooky plasma energy like ronda
byrne in the secret
he was giving off the the magnetism that
was negative to my polarity
or are we just talking about the fact
that your body is
able to sense things that the prefrontal
cortex
right the beginning the front of your
head isn't able to rationalize and isn't
able to articulate
now really that i think helps us to
redefine
spirituality away from all of
all of the trappings that it perhaps had
before and it's something that's a
little bit
easier for us to understand
abs you have done a lovely job of
summarizing my work for the past 25
years
some some college some call it uh
trans-rational this is
the rational and the logical
fully engaged fully all all systems go
and yet trans-rational also allows
for those other ways of knowing that
can't be measured with the standard
metrics and data
of cold rationalism and yet are just as
real
namely you crossed over the other side
of the street something within you
knew something you can rationally
explain it to me to a certain point
and then what you're going and
especially the person who's like i'm
just about the facts
yeah you just told me that you know so
and so is lying
give me the facts on how you know
they're lying i don't know it's
just a feeling oh it's interesting you
pride yourself on your facts
but actual lived experience you dip into
something you just called
feelings which sounds a little squishy
to me so apparently what you're actually
doing
is integrating these different modes
that are present within you
and sometimes you're going to move to
that town because the rent is cheaper
and you got a better job
and you can be closer to people you love
and there's a very rational process
and sometimes you went there because you
just knew
dear god it's time for a new start
and spiritual is the acknowledgement
that all that is in play with all of us
it's just a degree to which you own it
that's nice and this is the problem
in the western world and particularly
in the intellectual traditions that so
prized the one way of knowing
over other ways of knowing that you end
up with super smart people with two phds
who literally don't know how to have a
relationship
because what is the data on that show me
the research on that
it exists in different categories
or in the america we uh you have google
engineers
who are the hard like you said the cold
comfort of rationalism
and would mock anything spiritual or
religious but then can't wait to
show you the photos of their weekend at
bernie man
where they ran around half naked in the
desert
off the face of the psychedelic burning
effigy
yes saying oh man i was in touch with
the universal cosmic oneness
it's funny that you would say that
because that's a direct quote from
the old testament the bhagavad-gita the
upanishads
and buddhism even actually has a very
sophisticated
2000 year old way of naming what you
think is just i had mushrooms
and felt one taste so that's why
anytime someone starts banging on about
religion but then tells me about their
transcendent
experiences of freedom and liberation
i'm like you realize that in the book of
exodus
3 000 years ago they were telling a
story
to try and name the emptiness and
boundarylessness
of the formless divine
and that's where it gets real fun
there's a quote from
naval ravikant which i absolutely love
and he's talking about smart people
and it's very similar to what you've
just brought up there that we spend a
lot of time we dedicate ourselves to
expanding our cerebral capacity and
naval's question is if you're so smart
why aren't you happy
that's great that's great it's a killer
i love it
it's a real killer and it reminds us
again as well if
the fact that there is an upper bound i
i believe that there is an upper bound
on how much utilitarianism
and rationality can give us because
again there are boundaries to how well
we can rationalize
our own experiences the phenomenological
experience of being a human
is is it is so beyond
what our genes are doing and this is
completely compatible with evolutionary
psychology which has been a huge
influence on me over the last couple of
years absolutely um
the fact that uh let's say
let's say that you have got some bad
news like someone's
your girlfriend's message your
girlfriend that you've cheated on has
messaged you and said
we need to talk like that's you know
that's the single worst message to get
from anyone but like we need to talk
and that sensation where it feels like
all of your internal organs have dropped
to just above your pelvis
and you start sweating and it's cold
that sensation there
does not feel like some
genetic response which is you preparing
yourself for flight or flight
it feels like a curse bestowed on you by
a higher power
it feels like some sort of personal
bizarre torture method that has been
fired from
from some heavenly body that is able to
enact bizarre change on your internal
state
like that is phenomenologically what it
feels like
for that sensation to occur now you can
tell me that it's some different mix of
chemicals that go on in the brain
but that still doesn't actually
show us it doesn't explain to me how
that feels
absolutely and i and and what you're
pointing out is
when the person just keeps saying to you
it's chemicals
it's that desire to reduce the
experience
is funny because the person would say
i'm just sticking to the science
but then if you look at the history of
science all science has ever done
is show us how much more is going on
how much more complex it is we get a we
discover the higgs boson we get our
first picture of a black hole
and no scientist says well it's been a
good ride
and now we're done all that does
is just take us into new territories
of learning and exploration
so the person says to you basically no
no that experience we need to talk
let me just tell you all that was going
on there these were the chemicals
these were the neurons they reduce it
and what you are pointing out is yeah
but that same mindset
all it ever tells us about this
experience we're having
is as an expanding thing it's the
opposite of reduction
it's an opening up to all the things
that are happening
and that my god you follow that
and now you're back around to something
called spirituality
openness discovery exploration the two
are not the best scientists the best
mystic
the best poet the best analyst
at some point if they do their jobs you
arrive at wonder and awe
and you may have gotten there through
different rooms but you all end up you
end up in the same room with a house
which is very yeah
and that's the game that's the game to
be playing right there
what we need to talk i love that example
yeah i love that example big style
um what insight do you wish more people
knew
about life
that there is more going
on in any present moment
than anybody is actually aware of and
all the great wisdom traditions
take every yogi mystic sage
monk that went up and lived in a cave
you know what i mean the image they went
up and lived on a cave
to find the real answer to life they
never
ever come down from the mountain
a friend of mine has this great story
she says none of them ever came down and
said to everybody in the village hey i i
got the message
i figured it out and here's the thing
we're totally [ __ ]
like no one ever comes down they only
ever come down and say
here now
like right here and my work in some ways
for 20 years has been
creating spaces where people
can discover how much is in
this present moment the fact that you
and i have
made it through everything we made it
through and can have this conversation
like you and i could just take one step
back and be like
god that's pretty awesome or everybody
who listens to your podcast
you're here you're breathing you're
alive that can sound simplistic and sort
of yeah
no no no you're here whatever it is you
made it through it
every fear you've had about finances
you're here every fear you've ever had
about health
you're here you're thinking you're
engaging
like there is a mystery to consciousness
an extraordinary paradox that
is never not true
and especially as everything feels more
complicated
that becomes even more interesting
one of the things that i was really she
texted you she texted you and she said
we have to talk no no no rob this was
that was a hypothetical
that was a hypothetical thing that
wasn't me thank you
okay stitch me up from the other side of
the internet mate come on
um one of the things i've been thinking
a lot about recently
is the fact that one of the primary jobs
that our brains
have is not to allow us to perceive
things but actually to
stop us from perceiving things there's
far too many signals going on
for our brain to allow us to take them
all in
and one of the arguments for why
psychedelics
are so successful at giving people these
transcendent experiences that are
life-changing
is that these blockages the restrictions
upon
what you sense are dropped away
um so by its very nature your brain is
kind of
already playing this reductionist game
and
one of the things that yes i'm quite
keen to try and do
i i i'm kind of this is me rolling on
the crest of now trying to talk about
what's something that isn't fully formed
so it might come out messy
but my goal is to try and experience as
much as i can
in the moment to try and get rid of that
reductionist funnel
to try and permit myself to experience
the color as vibrantly as possible to
feel the wind on my skin
as fully as i can to smell the trees as
i walk past but to do them all at the
same time not to just
pick on one and pick on another and pick
on another to constantly have that sense
that immersion in experience the
immersion in being alive
and one of the things
that was really interesting to me was a
cue given by a guy called mark walsh
who runs the embodiment conference and
he said um a lot of the time when we're
when we're looking at something
we'll narrow our vision and one of the
cues that he gives people
is to just allow their peripherals to
open up so you're looking at whatever's
in front of you but you allow your
peripherals to open up
and you can see that i know that's a
very kind of basic example
but that's a perfect uh representation
of what happens when you
just realize that there's more beyond
the
the realm of senses that you have at the
moment if only you had the mindfulness
to be able to let it in
and when he as soon as he gave me that
cue the penny dropped
and i was like holy [ __ ] i'm doing that
with all of my senses
i'm choosing to only smell the things
that i'm expecting to smell because i
live the world through mental models i
don't live the world through experience
because it's a shortcut our brains are
there to make life easier for us we
don't need to make the choice of
what am i going to do with this how am i
going to think about that no no no
this situation similar to the one that
you had five years ago so just use that
model
you don't need to think about this i
don't need to learn something new i can
just do this
you've walked you've walked down your
street a thousand times before you don't
need to look at the color of the trees
you don't need to feel this the
wind on your skin you don't need to be
able to hear the birds in the trees
because you've heard them before you've
seen them before you've felt it before
and i think one of the goals that i have
certainly over the next
few years is to try and
work my mindfulness practice and my
ability to be present
up to the point at which i feel like i'm
feeling more
in the moment absolutely and there's
something
really interesting you pointed out
there's a there's a s a subtle
energetic posture that he invited you
in that actually is radically different
than the dominant energies
of the modern world because what he did
is he invited you to allow
and what's interesting about a lao is he
didn't say create
make hustle force dominate
he said allow which
is counter-intuitively a letting go
it's losing your life to find it
and the dominant energies of the modern
world
have often been mastery so like this is
the thing
most motivational speakers as lovely as
they can be
underneath it all the messages try
harder
it is do more it is reach within you
and when sometimes very very helpful but
nevertheless
also can be destructive override
whatever you're feeling in the moment
with energy passion whatever the
language is used
but what's interesting is
counter-intuitively
he said to you allow
yourself to have an experience of that
which is already present
and requires less energy
which is
the really interesting thing happening
now so
this man inviting you that at that
conference is people are realizing this
modern project
that taught us how to achieve how to
build podcasts how to talk to each other
across the ocean
how to build hospitals and airports and
put an
iphone in your pocket man we did all
this great stuff
and yet there is something
in that that formed these neural
pathways of the answer is always do more
heart try harder network hustle
and yet
there's also sit
become aware allow and there's a
world of wonder and mystery so
being in nature psychedelics meditation
i hit my head when i was 30. i had a
closed head injury i was doing backflips
water skiing
and i hit my head and i had a concussion
closed head injury
and i was introduced to my kids
so i saw my life outside of my life
and when they brought me back from the
hospital to my house
my wife gave me a tour of our house
this was 30 years old and then they
brought our two boys
into the room and i met my kids even
though i knew that they were mine at
some like cellular level
the brain was perceiving and then i
would
seriously chris i would say to kristin
my wife for for i took about a week for
my brain to go back to normal
i would ask kristin like how do we meet
what is my job
what do i do and i had
an altered state of
my brain couldn't do the past that was
too much energy and past is where regret
is
and my brain couldn't do future which is
where all the worry is
my brain could only be here and like
you're saying
all the brain could do was allow the
moment to be what it is
and it changed everything for me it was
that was right when the mall thing was
like at its sort of
fevered peak and it was like
oh my god this whole thing that i'm
doing over here
there's these present moments that i'm
in endlessly because only place you can
be is now
and there's more than you could ever
handle
right here i should probably be talking
about that
yeah man i mean again to to uh
how to paraphrase naval ravikant's quote
about the hustle pawn people like they
wouldn't have put the wick all the way
through the candle if you weren't
supposed to burn it at both ends
if you're working so hard why aren't you
happy
right like if you're if your work and
the volume of work that you're getting
done
is some form of achievement why aren't
you happy surely you should be more
happy
you're working harder like the work
should be in service of something which
is fulfilling and enjoying
so if you're working so hard why aren't
you happy
whatever that graph is they don't just
follow each other
neatly there's some way in which they
start whatever and then they just fly
off and different your xy graph
just goes to just yeah just gets
shredded i get it
rob man i've really enjoyed today uh
people want to check out
your work obviously everything is
spiritual who we are and what we're
doing here will be linked in the show
notes below anyone wants to go and check
it out on amazon
where else should they go
uh my site rabel.com has all the
episodes of the robcast we just released
a film called an
introduction to joy which is about the
pain and suffering
and temporal fleeting nature of life and
then there's
all sorts of sessions and there's a new
writing class coming and all that stuff
so rabel.com
amazing i'll link that below rob thank
you for today
i loved it i loved it i
had such wonderful things to say i'll be
thinking about them all day
you